while nick cannon continues to mourn the
loss of his five-month-old son a source
tells e.t his friends are worried about
him
i hold it my son
for the last time
but it was still it was a beautiful
setting
that was a 41 year old on tuesday
revealing on his daytime talk show that
his son zen died of brain cancer now e.t
source says his closest friends are
worried about him because it's been one
of the most trying times of his life
quote the reality of the situation has
been very difficult for him to absorb
when we found out it was more of a i
called it like a
a malignant tumor in his head
uh and so immediately we had to have
surgeries brain surgery we put a shunt
in his head and we were hoping for the
best but thanksgiving we had a uh
interesting term if anybody knows how
cancers were it was cancer in the brain
uh
and the the tumor
began to grow a lot faster
e.t source says that nick's friends are
rallying around him because quote they
know this type of pain will impact him
for the rest of his life adding quote
nick appreciates the support but at the
moment he just wants to be there for
zen's mother zen's mother is model
alyssa scott she opened up about the
heartbreaking loss on her instagram
posting a series of images and videos of
her newborn son
nick thanked alyssa on his show tuesday
praising her for her strength
alyssa was just a mate like the
strongest woman i've ever seen who was
emotional when she she needed to be but
was always the best mom and continues to
be the best mom possible now e.t source
says quote he wants nothing more than to
honor the time he had with zen and to
focus on being there for alyssa the
triple threat also welcomed twins zion
and zillion this year whom he shares
with dj and radio personality abby de la
rosa and while etisour says it's been a
quote beautiful year with the birth of
his kids quote nothing could have
prepared him for this
nick is the father to seven children
with four different women alyssa abby
model brittany bell and mariah carey and
e.t source says he feels so blessed to
have them adding he's very close to all
the women in his life family means
everything to him and this time has been
a reminder of that
and all that echoes what nick told et
back in september
what do you do in your downtime when you
do have some downtime kids you know i
got a lot of them that's why that's word
on the street cause you got a lot of
kids these days
they get my full attention when i'm not
not working it's like either work or
playing with my kids you're busy with
them kids right now that's what it is
that's that's what life is about that's
why we're on the planet and speaking of
work during his show tuesday nick opened
up about returning to the office so
quickly after the tragic loss
i didn't know how i was going to handle
today i didn't know
how but i i just really wanted
you know the i wanted to grieve with my
family
[Music]
people who love you
and e.t source explains that nick feels
lucky to have had the time he did with
his son but even more so a sense of
relief that zen is at peace quote nick
is incredibly spiritual and that has
helped to guide him through this but he
knows the true healing will take time
i didn't want to make it about any
pageantry or any of that type of stuff
so i kind of went back and forth for
what i should do but i felt like
you know i was always talking you know
just go through it you grow through it
you keep pushing you know what i mean
and i have so much faith in the lord